derrick may l'élu dit rick est aussi
j'ai été impressionné je fais ce que
j'ai à faire
tu parles comme un vrai soldat puis
certains tu reconnais son vieil ami le
vendeur
comment l'oublier il m'a tiré dans le
dos mais depuis deux ans ils sèment la
terreur partout autour du globe
[Musique]
une semaine le vendeur a volé du
matériel technologique
avec ça nous allons sont seulement
j'ai besoin de toi avec ton équipe sur
ce qu'on a on le fait à ma manière et
vous posez pas de questions j'embarque
d'accord je suis avec toi
j'aime pas cet endroit patron le vendeur
il s'en vient c'est ça si vous voulez
sur vire nous allons devoir collaborer
[Musique]
n'oubliez pas où les sommes nécessaires
et tous les avantages ou tard se sert de
ma fille pendant deux mois
tu as des enfants mais leur ramène plus
tôt ma petite fille allons-y
montre-toi montre toi où que tu sois
c'est vraiment pas quand il est temps de
rendre les armes et barbes toi
tu peux compter sur moi ça donne
[Musique]